en este vídeo vamos a hablar de dos
ideas relacionadas y que son la base de
la economía la idea de escasez y la idea
de rivalidad en otros vídeos hemos
hablado bastante de la escasez pero como
repaso recordemos que en el lenguaje
cotidiano la escasez se refiere a algún
servicio o bien del que no hay cantidad
suficiente para todos otra forma de
pensar en esto es aquel que está
limitado y del que hay una necesidad
potencialmente ilimitada podemos pensar
en muchos recursos escasos el petróleo
es un recurso escaso porque existe una
cantidad limitada de él y si el petróleo
fuera gratis habría una cantidad
ilimitada de gente que quiere usar ese
petróleo mucho en la economía trata de
cuando existe un recurso limitado como
el petróleo o la tierra o la vivienda
cómo asignar ese recurso entre las
personas que quieren usarlo la rivalidad
es una idea relacionada si pensamos en
el término rivalidad en el lenguaje
cotidiano podemos imaginar a muchas
personas compitiendo por algo lo cual se
acerca bastante a la definición de este
término en economía tenemos un bien
o un recurso rival si al ser ocupado por
una persona esto limita la posibilidad
de que sea usado por otras personas lo
escribimos un bien que al ser consumido
por una persona limita su disponibilidad
para que otros lo usen existen muchos
ejemplos de recursos o bienes que son
escasos y además son rivales por ejemplo
si yo trajera un delicioso pastel de
chocolate para cuatro personas a la
oficina en donde trabajamos 80 o 90
personas pueden estar seguros de que ese
pastel será un bien rival es un recurso
escaso porque el pastel no alcanzará
para todas las personas que lo quieren
comer pero cuando vemos la definición de
un bien rival entonces si yo me como
todo el pastel voy a limitar
definitivamente la capacidad de otras
personas de consumirlo a veces los
economistas crean espectros sobre qué
tanta rivalidad hay para cierto recurso
vamos a dibujar un espectro de ejemplo
aquí del lado izquierdo están los
recursos para los cuales hay mucha
rivalidad bienes rivales
del lado derecho están los recursos por
los cuales nadie compite bienes no
rivales del lado izquierdo hay muchos
ejemplos que podemos poner como recursos
rivales si vivimos en un lugar donde la
vivienda escasea entonces el alojamiento
es un bien rival si viven en tokio japon
si hay un departamento en renta habrá
muchas personas compitiendo por rentar
lo y si una persona renta ese
departamento
entonces limita la capacidad de otras
personas de usar ese departamento otro
ejemplo de bien rival es el terreno en
áreas urbanas o también podría ser un
pastel pequeño en una fiesta de
cumpleaños grande y que ejemplos hay en
el otro extremo del espectro de bienes
no rivales hay pocos ejemplos perfectos
de bienes no rivales pero hay ejemplos
que se acercan bastante porque dan la
impresión al menos por el momento de que
hay una oferta ilimitada de ellos un
ejemplo que se acerca bastante al
extremo es el aire aire para respirar en
este momento no es un bien rival porque
si yo respiro profundamente no estoy
evitando que alguien más respire
profundamente al mismo tiempo vamos
agregar el calificativo de
simultáneamente es un calificador clave
para un bien rival por ejemplo un
martillo es un bien rival porque si yo
lo estoy usando en este momento va a ser
muy difícil que alguien más lo use
simultáneamente vimos el ejemplo del
aire si yo respiro profundamente no
impido que alguien más también lo haga
pero si nos encontramos en una situación
extrema como en un cuarto sellado con
una cantidad limitada de oxígeno
entonces el aire se acerca mucho a ser
un bien rival lo ponemos aquí a
diferencia del aire para respirar afuera
en este extremo el oxígeno en un cuarto
cerrado se acerca mucho a ser un bien
rival en un cuarto cerrado que se está
quedando sin oxígeno
cada vez que yo respiro profundo voy a
dificultar que otra persona lo haga y
viceversa otro ejemplo de bienes rivales
son las carreteras especialmente en la
hora pico mientras más autos transitan
por la carretera más difícil será para
las personas usarlas simultáneamente
habrá mucho tráfico y los autos no
podrán moverse en ellas pero por otra
parte podemos imaginar las mismas
carreteras
madrugada y en ese momento no son bienes
rivales si quiero conducir a las 3 de la
mañana por alguna de estas carreteras
seguramente no haré que sea más difícil
para otra persona conducir por la misma
carretera al mismo tiempo las carreteras
a las 3 am son un recurso muy cercano a
ser un bien no rival
vamos a dejarlo aquí estás son ideas que
seguiremos analizando en la economía
pero es bueno tener una idea de lo que
significan después nos informaremos
sobre cómo asignar estos recursos
escasos entre las personas que los
demandan y pensaremos en cómo asignar
estos bienes rivales entre personas que
compiten por ellos nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo